vai falar de terapia gênica de robôs
inteligência artificial
eu quero trazer para vocês hoje uma
inovação é incrível uma tecnologia que
pode impactar a vida de milhões de
pessoas
quero falar aqui é um recurso que pode
nos ajudar a desenvolver nosso sistema
imunológico nosso sistema neurológico e
respiratório que comprovadamente pode
evitar doenças como diabetes asma
doenças autoimunes alergias
quero falar aqui de um procedimento que
apesar de ser relativamente barato
ele não está disponível para a maior
parte das pessoas nesse país
eu estou falando do parto vaginal porque
eu falo que não está disponível para a
maior parte das pessoas
hoje neste país - metade das pessoas na
acim pelos meios naturais e sim através
de uma cirurgia
apesar da organização mundial de saúde
preconiza que 80 a 90 por cento das
pessoas deveria ser dessa maneira
e apesar de saber que 70% da gestante
nesse país começa a gravidez desejando
parto normal que acontece que a gente
está deixando de entregar para as
gestantes e principalmente quais são as
consequências dessa realidade algumas a
gente já sabe por exemplo que o brasil
fracassou em cumprir as metas com a
organização de um mundial de saúde de
reduzir mortalidade materna são duas mil
mães que morrem todos os anos em
decorrência de complicações do parto
nossa taxa de prematuridade a alta
são 50 mil prematuros heatrow genéricos
por ano - mais que a promotoria
transgênico é aquela criança que foi
retirada do útero antes da hora antes de
37 semanas
sem justificativa é uma conseqüência
desastrosa que a gente precisa mudar com
que a gente muda isso dessa realidade
vamos imaginar então qual seria o
cenário ideal imaginar uma grávida que
nasce um país rico com o melhor sistema
de saúde do mundo privilegiada como
seria o quarto dela
vou trazer que o exemplo bem noticiado
pela empresa da kate middleton a duquesa
de cambridge como foco as partes dela
teve três partes normais chilenas
notícias que ela foi dirigindo em
trabalho de parto na maternidade ela
voltou para casa andando de salto alto
seis horas depois de um homem que pode
qual é a diferença que ela recebeu da
sociedade que permitiu a ela tem uma
situação tão diferente da nossa
será que foi ter acesso ao melhor
hospital com os melhores recursos com a
melhor tecnologia com a melhor equipe de
obstetras
eu acredito até porque ela mal ficar no
hospital
ela não consumiu recursos tecnológicos
do cti
os obstetras nem entrado na sala de
parto
quem fez os passos dela foram 2000 do
ice duas parteiras
então qualquer diferença para a nossa
realidade é falta de tecnologia
eu acredito que é uma mudança de cultura
que é necessária como é a cultura hoje
dá atenção ao parto e à gravidez no
brasil a cultura do medo é a cultura do
consumo do risco nossas gestantes vivem
com medo
como a gente pode mudar isso que a gente
pode mudar
usando isso aqui está disponível cada um
de vocês tem um bolso tem mais celular
que a gente neste país
eu começo a falar um pouco do projeto no
qual tenho dedicado aos últimos cinco
anos
sou médico de família seu pai da sofia
o davi e da flora estou falando do
canguru canguru gravidez é um aplicativo
que pode ser resumido com um facebook de
grávida
o google de conteúdo clínico para a
gestação um brinquedinho de
profissionais de saúde e um tripé de
várias maternidades
como que a gente pode mudar isso
a gente entrega para ela uma rede de
gestantes na qual você pode se apoiar
pode conversar e interagir trocar
experiências síkora já a gente coloca em
contato com profissionais engajados na
causa entrega pra ela conteúdo clínico
de relevância elaborado por
profissionais que ela é capaz de
compreender adaptado para uma linguagem
sensível informa ela as condições do
serviço de saúde que estão na região na
hora que assim que a gente pretende
ajudar a mudar essa cultura mais de 300
mil grávidas já usar o aplicativo no
país em 20 por cento das cidades do país
alguém já usou e hoje eu tenho a alegria
de falar que a gente vai chegando perto
do nosso objetivo alguns indícios já que
a gente pode realmente impactar na vida
dessas pessoas das famílias né porque
tem a mãe tem o pai da criança tem os
demais familiares e hoje posso dizer com
alegria que a gente tem uma taxa de
parto normal entre os usuários do
aplicativo de 60%
eu não quero entrar na questão parto
normal vc dessa cesariana não é essa
questão mas sim de esperar o momento
certo
a gente sabe que desencadeia o trabalho
de parto
são substâncias que beber libera quando
ele está pronto para nascer
então por que não esperar o momento
certo vou deixar de dizer agora porque
colhendo o fruto antes da hora
a gente sabe que foi fruto colhido antes
da hora nunca vai chegar no seu
desenvolvimento completo na sua doçura
completa
então vamos observar a natureza não
respeitar a natureza
vamos dar uma rede de apoio para essas
mães que ela para que elas possam
esperar esse momento e encará lo como um
momento de alegria de vida como deve ser
a gente tende a medir a saúde como se
fosse um acelerador
quanto mais a gente investe
quanto mais recurso tecnológico melhor
que a gente sabe que não é assim às
vezes menos é mais e aceitar ser técnico
hoje atenção ao parto e atenção à a ao
pré natal mostra pra gente claramente
que é preciso acelerar um pouco e vamos
parar de pensar em acelerador
vamos pensar na balança às vezes o ideal
a gente encontrar um equilíbrio para
finalizar eu queria aproveitar a
campanha dia das mães que perguntassem a
uma gestante na platéia
eu queria pedir uma salva de palmas em
homenagem a essas gestantes ea todas as
mães do país
obrigado